hey everyone welcome to another session
by simplygon in the previous few videos
you learned all about UI path and it's
working and sure that gave you a brief
insight into RPF in today's video we
learn all about our pH job roles and
responsibilities saturdays and a sample
resume I am sure this video will clarify
all your doubts regarding our PA and its
career path but before we begin check
out our courses if you wish to make a
career in our PA you could head to our
official website and check out the
courses
all right so without further ado let's
begin here's what we'll be learning
today who is an RP a developer RP a
growth projections RP a job roles happy
a developer responsibilities RP
developer sanity and RP a developer
sample resuming so let's begin by
understanding who is an RP a developer
now generally speaking an RP developer
is someone who works cross-functionally
with business operations and business
analysts to create an optimized workflow
processes however this is a relatively
new career path and many organizations
formal titles for RP developers Depot
now other similar positions may include
titles like process designer or
automation architect but no matter the
title the rule of a successful RP
developer involves to design develop and
implement RPS systems in order to
automate the business process and RP a
developer will be required to create
workflow diagrams and strategically
document the implementation he's also
responsible for bug fixes so coding
skills are important now in order to be
a successful RP developer you must have
the ability to navigate various
appropriate technologies such as UI path
or automation anywhere next up is RTA
growth projections
now looking at the curve both RP in
software and services increased by huge
amounts between 2016 and 2020 and beyond
according to McKinsey research knowledge
and work automation could have an
economic impact of about 5 to 7 trillion
u.s. dollars for the year 2025 it will
touch more than 230 million knowledge
workers which constitute up to 9% of the
global workforce now any company which
is labor-intensive the people are
performing high volume high transaction
functions will boost their capabilities
and save money and time without you now
that we've established that RPI has the
steep growth curve let's look at the RPI
job roles that you should look out for
we have the art a developer senior art
either bubble how to process architect
happy developer senior consultant
project manager the developer business
analyst and our P theta our
now these job roles come with specific
responsibilities depending on the
designation however there are a few
common responsibilities of an RP
developer let's go ahead and set them up
now the first one is to teach it
planning skills now planning is a
crucial phase in any development
lifecycle the RP developer regardless of
the designation suppose as the aptitude
can show us the teacher planning
planning includes the design development
and implementation of our PA systems
this also helps streamline the business
next up is strong analytical skills now
to understand the clients requirements
and cater to the needs of coding lis is
crucial analytical skills are also
important to predict or identify
potential bugs and errors and rectify
them now this scale is especially
required if you're involved in the
overall development next we have strong
problem-solving skills now this again is
extremely crucial to predict any outages
and they put the entire unit to overcome
any unforeseen interruptions from the
business perspective as well
problem-solving skills play a
significant role in ensuring smooth
conduction of tasks experienced in any
programming language such as C C++
Python Ruby Java or.net is also
important hands-on experience from our
pH tools and cognitive platform that has
blue prism automation anywhere uipath
opens BAM etc is necessary communication
skills are pivotal for any organization
the developer should be outspoken and
articulate any new ideas he should also
be confident early if confirmed and be
as transparent as possible in the long
run this only proves to be helpful to
the organization lastly we have exposure
to SQL our experience with database the
SQL or no sequel is highly preferred
there's always an added advantage if you
have the knowledge about accessing and
managing databases
next up we have RP developer Saturdays
now the salaries will differ depending
on the location your experience and also
the designation now in the US here are
the job salaries and the roles
according to Glassdoor an RP a developer
in the u.s. earns around 76 thousand US
dollars per year then RP develop a
senior consultant earns around ninety
nine thousand US dollars per EUR in RP a
process architect earns an average
salary of ninety five thousand US
dollars and the senior RP a developer
earns an average salary of ninety two
thousand US dollars an RP a project
manager earns around seventy-three
thousand US dollars per annum an RP lead
developer earns an average salary of
ninety nine thousand US dollars per
annum ten RP a business analyst earns
around sixteen thousand US dollars per
annum and the data analyst earns around
sixty two thousand US dollars per annum
moving on to India the average salary of
an RP developer is around 5 lakhs 19
thousand rupees that of a senior
consultant a senior RP developer and an
RP lead developer is around 14 lakhs per
annum and the avatar you cannot be a
business analyst is around 5 lakhs
40,000 rupees now let me quickly run you
through a sample resume of an RP a
developer now this is just a template
and you can alter it according to your
needs first up is a general information
like name phone number and your email id
then you can get the quick description
about yourself and your strengths you
can also mention the objective as to why
you're applying and what you looking for
in the organization you can include your
LinkedIn profile link and your github
link one look at your LinkedIn profile
is enough for anybody to gather all the
information necessary so make sure that
it's updated moving on you could mention
it experience now here I would have to
mention the names of your previous
organizations along with your
designation and the tenure you could
also include your key responsibilities
in these organizations along with the
responsibilities you can also mention
the awards that you received in your
organization's next up is their
educational background
you can mention the University of the
graduated form and this require that you
have a degree in computer science you
can also go ahead and mention your GPA
the next section is skills now this is
pretty crucial in the technical skills
section you could mention about dippin
RP tools that you've worked on you feel
good at a particular programming
language go ahead and mention that as
well as mentioned earlier any experience
in database management is an added
advantage if you have any experience go
ahead and mention that moving on to
non-technical skills you could mention
any extracurricular activities that
you're proud of some soft skills that
you feel worth mentioning can be added
in this section mentioning the languages
that we know can also boost your resume
now given all this is fundamental that
will not lie on your resume all right
then
with that we conclude this session I
hope it gave you a clearer understanding
of the subject thank you so much for
being here keep learning and sleep it
into something wrong hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simple
learn youtube channel and click here to
watch similar videos to nerd up and get
certified
click here